وليه المزيد حول هذا الموضوع مع الان عبر
الهاتف من دبي الاستاذ سيد غنيم اهلا
ومرحبا بكنا استاذ زائر في منظمه حلف
الشمال الاطلسي والاكاديميه العسكريه
بروكسل بدايه استاذ يعني تبادل الاتهامات
مستمر منذ اشهر بقصف هذه المحطه محطه
سافوريتشا اناويه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه اليوم هذه المحطه التي يعني هي
قريبه من جبهه القتال برايك يعني كيف يتم
همم التاكد منهيه الجهه التي اا تقوم بهذا
النوع من العمليات
اهلا وسهلا يا فندم الدكتور سيد وليد مع
حضرتك
الحقيقه التاكد من خارج منطقه القتال صعب
للغايه
كان موجود ويمكن حتى فرنسا 24 كان لها سبق
انها نشرت لحظه بلحظه تواجد الفريق القادم
من وكاله الطاقه الذريه التابعه للامم
المتحده الذي كان يتابع الموقف بنفسه في
شهر سبتمبر كما تتذكرين وكانوا متواجدين
ووعدوا انهم لن يغادر المكان
برئاسه مندوبهم المتحده هو هم الموحدون
رغم انهم غير عسكريين لا يستطيعوا تحديد
من اي اتجاه تتم الضربات الا ان له يعني
ردا على سؤالك او نفهم هو صعب بالتحديد
صعب التحديد ولكن همم يعني
محطه للطاقه النوويه وظيفتها الرئيسيه
لانها توفر 20% من الطاقه الكهربائيه
لاوكرانيا
وتبقى للمرحله القتال التي انا اسميها
المرحله الرابعه في الحقيقه التي نحن فيها
الان كل الجهود الروسيه تستهدف البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه الكهربائيه الاوكرانيه
المدنيه
وده هذا بيداعم فكره ان روسيا هي من
تستهدف بشكل اكبر او بشكل اكبر تاكيدا
باقي مصادر الطاقه الكهربائيه للجانب
الاوكراني بهدف انها تراهن على ارادته ان
يجعل للاراده الروسيه
ولكن في رايي ان ان ان الاهم الان وهو
واضح من مطلب الامم المتحده طبقا لتقريرك
الرائع من دقائق انتم تلعبون بالنار هم لا
يهمهم بالتحديد من المتسبب او من الفاعل
بقدر يهمهم التوقف فورا على هذا
التصرفولي لانه مدمر للجميع لان المشكله
تم اغلاق المفاعلات التي تحدث الاشعاع
ولكن بالرغم ذلك ان حاله اصابه المبردات
لانه هناك مبردات تبرد الوقود النووي
بسخونه الوقود النووي برغم الشتاء كان دوت
هيشرب اشعاع ايضا رغم اغلاق المفاعلات هنا
تاتي الخطوره وهي بصراحه مدمره لانها هذه
تستمر الاشعاع لفتره طويله في هذه المنطقه
الاقل الدكتور سيد غنيم الاستاذ زائر في
منامه حلف شمال الاطلس والاكاديميه
العسكريه ببروكسيل اشكرك على كل هذه
توضيحاتكم معنا عبر الهاتف من